mr. speaker the cabinet has given high
speed rail the green signal we are going
to get this done and to ensure that we
do so without further blowouts allow the
cost or schedule we are today taking
decisive action to restore discipline to
the program I will be appointing a
minister whose full-time job will be to
oversee the project a new ministerial
oversight group will be tasked with
taking strategic decisions about it
there will be changes to the way hs2 is
managed we will in line with mr. Kerr
these recommendations be interrogating
the current costs to identify where
savings can be made in phase 1 without
the costs and delays that would be
associated with a detailed redesign and
so that the company can focus solely on
getting phases 1 & 2 a built on
something approaching time and budget I
will be creative new delivery
arrangements for both the grossly behind
schedule
Houston terminus and phase 2b of the
wider project but before those designs
are finalized and legislation introduced
we will also present an integrated plan
for rail in the north
informed by an assessment from the
National Infrastructure Commission it
will in line with the findings of the
OCO V review look at how we can best
design at integrate rail investments
across the north including northern
powerhouse rail between Leeds and
Manchester and I've just spoken to the
mayor of Greater Manchester who has
warmly welcomed this project which I
committed to supporting by the way eyes
need remember during my first days in
office
you